something's not right  enjoy some time with the family on this  beautiful day there we can stop them all  time travels risky if we do it right we  can reset everything back to the way it  should be  welcome to prehistoric times yeah I know  this is extremely confusing but we're  all very much alike  welcome to Merlin's castle there's a  short metal dragon  good luck with that bye the vortex is  collapsing come on let's go  this john ii job let's go kill some  sharks come on  the British are throwing slide sharks at  us  how was that maybe that's how sharks  evolved over the last 20,000 years  can't wait to see what the humans look  like Planet of the aprile's  you